le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
dans quelques années une croissance
économique et démocratique importante
des entreprises se sont implantées dans
la région sud et beaucoup de commerces
se sont ouverts c'est donc très
logiquement que de plus en plus de
familles ont fait le choix de
s'installer près de leur lieu de travail
en contrepartie les collectivités en
premier lieu les communes doivent
répondre aux besoins de ces nouvelles
populations
les logements sont insuffisants mais
aussi les établissements scolaires
les jeunes qui habitent doivent se
contenter de classes surchargées des
conditions difficiles pour offrir un
apprentissage scolaire de qualité alors
comment continuer à développer sa région
tout en offrant une scolarité de qualité
on en parle maintenant dans lien social
au 12e kilomètres que se trouve ce
collège tout neuf un établissement
pouvant accueillir des classes allant de
la sixième à la troisième le quartier
est en effervescence depuis quelques
temps car ce collège flambant neuf
apporte aux habitants du quartier une
solution au problème de classe
surchargés et aux difficultés de
proximité un outil très apprécié des
habitants mais aussi des professeurs et
du service administratif du collège les
établissements du tampon étant saturés
en effectif le Conseil général a pris la
décision avec l'état de construire un
collège supplémentaire
naturellement le Conseil général a pris
en charge tout ce qui est de l'ordre de
la construction du bâtiment et donc nous
avons travaillé en très étroite
collaboration avec les équipes de la vie
éducative du conseil général les parents
il est difficile de parler à leur place
je crois que ils sont
tout d'abord contents d'un outil de
proximité
ils sont contents que le collège est
ouvert quasiment en temps en temps et
heure je pense que ils doivent aussi
être satisfait de
du désengorgement des autres collèges du
fait de l'ouverture du collège du 12e et
en particulier le désengorgement du
collège du 14e qui devenait critique je
pense qu'une entrée en 6e si on se
souvient nous-mêmes c'est quelque chose
c'est un grand changement de donc avoir
en même temps une entrée en 6ème et un
établissement neuf qui termine de
s'installer je pense que c'est quelque
chose dont il se souviendront
effectivement je pense qu'ils sont pour
le moment en tout cas il me semble
satisfait
le passage en sixième est un événement
important dans la vie scolaire passer de
l'école primaire à l'enseignement
secondaire est un tournant pour un
enfant et quand les conditions sont
réunies pour faire une belle rentrée
scolaire on augmente ses chances de
réussir son année de sixième
accessible que nous partons quand on a
des questions à poser au
personnel administratif sur place et
puis donc
facilité dans les démarches de cette
administratives parce qu'il y a moyen
de tout le monde
c'est tout simple c'est plus ça pour les
enfants ils sont dans le quartier ils se
connaissent déjà et puis bon voilà c'est
plus facile pour eux de d'aller chez eux
plus facilement on va dire comme ça
le confort des enfants dans leur vie
scolaire et quelque chose d'important le
Conseil général est sensible aux
conditions que propose les
établissements scolaires pour le
département une jeunesse cultivée et
instruite est une jeunesse qui a plus de
chance de réussir dans une vie
professionnelle pour cette raison il met
tous les moyens utiles et nécessaires et
offre à la réunion des établissements de
grande qualité nous on poursuit notre
politique de construction de collège
c'est aussi améliorer les conditions
d'accueil de nos collégiens plus de
60000 collégiens depuis quelques années
on est dans une dynamique malgré la
crise malgré les difficultés économiques
d'essayer de rééquilibrer le territoire
et aussi de prendre en compte tous les
critères démographiques et je suis à le
tampon c'est aussi
j'allais dire à essayer aussi d'alléger
certains collèges qui sont plein et
aujourd'hui avec cette rentrée on va
faire l'ouverture du 12e on a commencé
en 2011 la construction de ce collège là
c'est aussi un partenariat avec tout le
monde avec commune du Tampon nous-mêmes
la nouveauté si on construit une liste
aussi pour les élèves avec des handicaps
avec tous les équipements modernes
d'école de musique l'école de sport etc
avec des espaces et donc quelque part
c'est vraiment améliorer le confort de
nos élèves améliorer la proximité aussi
nous aujourd'hui on est dans une
politique où on veut vraiment
rééquilibrer le territoire et de l'autre
côté aussi c'est de dire on se donne les
moyens pour regarder l'avenir ensemble
la réussite de nos enfants dépend
beaucoup de leur réussite scolaire qu'il
choisisse de travailler dans le
département ou à l'étranger le Conseil
Général fait le nécessaire pour suivre
et soutenir les jeunes car leur offrir
un avenir meilleur c'est offrir un
meilleur avenir à la Réunion
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais